Will Smith might have got a lot of
attention for taking on the in my
feelings dance challenge on the top of a
bridge and Budapest but Drake knows that
will isn't the one who deserves all the
credit for starting the social media
craze that song is number one on
Billboard this week crazy know it all
started on the date of Drake's album
came out that the Shiggy show countered
the argument that there's no bangers
right dance doing scorpion he took to
the streets the dance my feelings and I
went viral it's now number one and
yesterday you can hear Drake thanking
shaggy off-camera Ruiz now before we
talk about the songs Croesus success
here's the latest celebs to do it milli
Bobby Brown and no snap on the set of
stranger things season 3
[Music]
joe says on YouTube he loves the Will
Smith one that's things till Drake never
promoted this as a single no it wasn't
supposed to be the Michael Jackson one
was supposed to be the next song right
and then just and then this just happens
but you just kind of falls into his
hands like there's people that work so
hard to try to get a hit single like
perform it everywhere do a music video
all this stuff releases the radio Drake
it just had to sit back yeah and watch
this song just explode I don't yeah so
we'll see he was shooting a music video
this week in London yeah you think it
would still be in my feelings musically
feel like he probably wants to fuel it
on I don't know like because this could
be the song of the summer this yeah
keeps up that's crazy it's just crazy
like Drake's had to do nothing that's
the way that's that's the the way it
happens yeah I mean it is and again when
people would release these you know it
used to be that you would set out an
album with 10 or 12 songs on it and it
was dictated by the people in charge of
what was going to be the first release
second release the release and they had
a plan and it was like a two-year plan
of when singles were gonna drop
depending on where you were on tour what
was gonna get pushed all this stuff and
it doesn't that doesn't exist anymore
because it doesn't matter what your plan
is a youtuber is gonna turn the song
into the song of the summer like that
there's nothing you can do about it yeah
so you're wondering it out they've
switched things up cuz they I will see
what that yeah well they may have been
like this is gonna be the song of
Christmas right you know that may have
been their plan you will get to that
eventually but that's it well let's say
let's see your dance moves I already did
it a couple weeks oh you haven't done
I've mastered it but you will never see
it